check check one two ladies and gentlemen
welcome in
hello hello hello and welcome to another
day of Harry Potter magic awakened
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
and as you can see here we are in year
two of Harry Potter magic awakened
that's right Dylan another day
another retro live
and it's happy uh it's I'm happy
to be streaming it live here with you
guys so here's where we are at in our
breakdown right now so we've done a
couple in part two already but I just
noticed this up here I didn't even
realize
look at this up here
Owen welcome in
more retro more retro indeed
I didn't even realize when I get to the
end of it here we get a random legendary
card each legendary card has an equal
chance of appearing
I just got the speaking of Elwyn I just
got the Phoenix earlier Elwyn
I just got the legendary phoenix I was
so pumped I got it through the uh the
special event that's ongoing right now
actually haven't even taken a look at it
yet here in my
in my deck you know what let's go ahead
and let's
I want to do
level cost
let's do it by cost there it is right
there
there's the Phoenix Summons of Phoenix
which will continuously heal Ally units
within range at the cost of its own
health
Phoenix will leave a pile of Ashes once
its Health has been depleted from which
it will rise after a period of time oh
man it costs seven to play it though
didn't realize that
after three resurrections the Phoenix
will return to your hand when it's
health
is depleted again the Phoenix's Max
health is reduced by 10 every time it's
Reborn
huh I'm not
excuse me I'm not seeing a lot of people
playing it but maybe that's just because
a lot of people don't have it I don't
know but it doesn't I mean it doesn't
sound like
let's take a look at the little video
here
they put the Phoenix out oh and it just
continuously it keeps healing that it'd
be great to use Inc in conjunction with
that's that's two legendary cards right
there though
Metatron welcome in Nico what's up Nico
how's it going Ryan good to see you over
here Ryan
Lauren how's it going Ryan
wow did I just like I just said one name
and then
Lauren how's it going welcome in good to
see you as well
yeah we've been streaming uh been doing
some back and forth streaming over here
some streaming on Twitch some as well
so we did make it to platinum in Solo
duels we finally made it to platinum we
did indeed
uh mad girl welcome in thank you for
subscribing good to see you here Alicia
welcome annalisha
and Trisha Channel member right there
Alicia Channel member welcome in guys
welcome in Elwyn Nico of course channel
members as well also Dylan getting us
started there
and then I missed somebody
Dev how's it going Dev no there is not
an official app for PC well depending on
where you live
depending on where you live in some
areas you can actually you can download
it anywhere in the world but you can
only play it in certain regions so I am
using an emulator called BlueStacks on
Android so you can check it out down in
the video description below all the
details on that and it's free free to
download but I am a BlueStacks affiliate
so if you use my link it goes to support
the channel
but again it is a Oh India
I'm not sure I'm not sure but yeah if
you just go to uh the the worldwide
website on Magic awaken you can download
a PC client and then you the official PC
client and you can see which ones are
um whenever you go to pick your region
because I downloaded it just to try it
I'm in the US and so I thought let's
give this a shot it lets you download it
it lets you run it but whenever you get
to select your server it's just like
locked out on the US so
and I also just got another one of these
cards earlier so I can upgrade this now
I'm actually really excited about that
1500 the little bomb box man this thing
is crazy
this could put out a lot of damage that
just took it up to level nine right
there
foreign
thank you Elwyn yes indeed all right so
I'm gonna try to finish out the story I
don't think it will take me too long
let's see we've got let's see we've got
this chapter this chapter or I guess
this section of a chapter so that's two
three four five six seven eight
oh wow 9 10 11 12 30 14.
okay maybe it'll take me longer than I
thought
it might take longer than I thought so I
better stop talking and dive in here
let's talk to Hagrid get this moving
Hagrid how's it going
hey Nico with the 11 months uh
appreciate it Nico
yeah I it's so different than Legacy Dev
but I'm so glad that both of them exist
I did not think I would like this one as
much as I'm liking it but I am I am so
into it there's something so into it
some young wizard might have a set of
sticky fingers
and by that I mean someone's been
stealing things
the voice actor for Hagrid so actually a
lot of the voice acting is really good
and I don't think they used any of the
any of the actors from the movies or
anything poison cakes mostly Sam on the
table are cool and next thing you know
they're gone
thought maybe you were fine except he's
been with me this whole time
Elysee new to the game nice me too
well sort of I've been playing for about
a week when it launched worldwide that's
when I started playing I'm sure we can
try let's see if they left any clues
behind yeah George George is really good
all right so we need to investigate
yeah Lauren it's like
that's why I was always kind of turned
off because I'm not really I don't play
a lot of mobile games
but playing this on a PC it he'll be
lucky to have anything I mean aside from
Graphics you know it feels like a
full-fledged PC game
a full-fledged MMO
all right so wait are we already done
inspect the stairs inspect the pumpkins
and inspect the fence okay there are a
few feathers
yeah if any of you new players have any
questions anything you want to know
about the game let me know we might have
some videos here on the channel already
answering it if not I might be able to
answer it live or I might be able to
make a future video about it
all right so we inspected those now we
need to do the fins
which I don't really need that I can
just follow
the little Golden Trail
the whole card thing yeah I didn't think
I would like the car thing either but
I'm so in
I am so in
it's also cool because it's like it
gives like this collector
aspect to it
all right Hagrid how's it going did you
find any clues
a few we did
think it was a suspicious wizard who
stole your food Hagrid I think it might
have simply been a hungry bird
a bird with multi-colored feathers that
also happens to be capable of
teleportation so you might turn this up
just a hair
you guys can hear it a little bit better
if my suspicions are correct
it'll probably reappear any second yo
let's go Dylan that's awesome dude
if my suspicions are correct it'll
probably reappear any second
there it is
your WB account is not linking
oh I don't know about that one
yeah I'm not sure about that
you might have to reach out to them uh
the WB Games support was very active on
Twitter during the Hogwarts Legacy
launch I don't know if they've been
responding a lot on this but you might
want to try that
is there a storyline yeah
yeah I completed chapter one and this is
chapter two that we're doing right now
battle all right we gotta take out this
bird I guess
[Music]
stealing my food all this time it was a
deer recall
could change your character you could
change a lot of stuff about your
character
you can change uh
you know the hairstyles what they're
wearing appearances all those things
when all your duels so far nice yeah it
starts off like you get your first
couple of uh
they put you just against AI for a bit
and then when you get out of that then
you start going against humans I think
it's it's novice then silver then gold
gold starts to get pretty tough
and then I just hit Platinum yesterday
and I actually haven't done any matches
in it I just I hit it and was like
I'm good for now Dylan we we need to
like start oh is there bronze I forgot
about bronze that's right
Dylan we need to start grinding some uh
Duo duels we're both gold now see if we
can get up there to platinum
okay someone's Hager to ride his
motorbike this will increase your
movement speed and deal damage yeah yeah
we have this one
you want me to use it now
all right Hagrid let's do this
are we just supposed to take out the
Gnomes oh catch the deer call okay
you need to drive over here
is that it
I bet we have to fight all these things
off first oh now it's over here of
course
it's trying to evade us we need that
special bag like in Hogwarts Legacy
that's what we need
now he's moving over here
come here you
oh my gosh okay is there a secret that
I'm missing here there we go all right I
was about to say
gold duels look so difficult
what what have you been uh running
primarily Dylan because I'm still
I I Bella my Bellatrix is what took me
all the way to platinum on solo
but I'm not sure if Bellatrix is the
play in Duos all right let's go ahead
and land all right what do you got next
Force Hagrid
we did it
I guess you don't have to worry about
this one stealing any more of your food
where can you change your hair pick a
wizard instead of a witch there you go
Alicia Madame malkin's and Diagon Alley
oh but I think you can change your
I think you can change your hair anytime
you just have to get another alternate
here I'll show you
let me get out of this little
cap don't worry little fella you're
gonna take care of him Hagrid of course
Hagrid's gonna take care of him
now there's a story that's what I'm
doing right now
you go through their first year in
chapter one and then this is their
second year chapter two
suppose he left a share won't he
suppose you'll have to share with me
my door is always open
yeah from the mirror yeah without a spot
of tea I could use something to calm me
down after all this activity
okay yeah so all right we have like a
couple questions here so for Story
related stuff
this is where you go right here so see
I'm in year two right now of the story
that's what we're progressing here so
whenever you go to your tasks you want
to click the one that says story
and that's where you do all the story
related stuff then you have like your
your daily stuff and then you have the
seasonal things which this one runs
through
August 22nd there
and then the question about changing out
your appearance if you go down to your
knapsack
and then you go to the new look mirror
right here
New Look mirror
so you can see different hairstyle but I
I don't even have a lot actually I need
to check in with uh yeah I do not want
to save my current look anyway so
and then Lauren's question about yeah I
mean I'm playing like totally solo right
now and then I mean there's a lot of
things that you can do solo
and then there's a lot of things that
you can do with what they call like
your companions in the game
and those are things that you could do
with real people
so you can do them with companions as
well
all right so next we need to look for
Daniel at the potions classroom
all right so let's just go ahead and
fast travel there
your Hagrid deck gotcha could use a
different Echo that would suit it you
love the cards yeah
well I don't know how much you were able
to watch yesterday Dylan but a lot of
those high level players in there were
saying that don't worry so much about
the cards on the Echoes right now
because I was doing the same thing but
they said don't worry so much about them
because it really doesn't come into play
until you're at much higher level
so I was like okay good because I've
really been like stressing over this
Echo doesn't really match what I want in
the cards I knew there was something in
here
Draco lurking while you're doing some
duels sounds good
yeah Draco I don't know what happened
yesterday like
after the stream I hopped on once we got
the kids in bed
and I was like you know what let's try
this Bellatrix deck again switched out a
few things that I thought I was a little
bit more familiar with and just started
just really started uh
smashing through people all right Daniel
what's going on
I can't believe it I was brewing a
potion when my gloves fell off straight
into my cauldron
that's not good you better get a new
pair
preferably ones made with dragon skin
all this is good because I actually
wanted to go here anyway I want to check
in at Madame malkins I need to start
checking every day because I I
definitely want some better uh
oh what do we have here
wait what was it
what was that
I don't know what just happened there
but
all right I want to check in here first
Daniel
I haven't found anything I really like
yet in the in Madame malkin's shop
how often does this change do you guys
know I kind of like this one right here
the red Newt one
I like these I like that one right there
but you can only get that through the
mystery wheel
yeah sorry madam Malkin you haven't seen
it change at all yet yeah I don't I
don't know why that wouldn't change out
so often
all right look for Daniel at the potions
classroom what
we just talked to him he said he was
coming here
Daniel
bro what the heck
oh wait did I just do interact with him
hi Daniela thanks again for clicked on
the wrong thing before
uh map is in the top left of most
screens
you just tap on that and then you have
all the different little categories
now don't apologize for questions all
good
that's why one of the reasons I like to
do these streams is try and help you
guys out and it's a lot man this game
there's a lot of menus there's a lot of
currency we just posted a video on that
yesterday if you guys haven't checked
that one out explaining all the
different
money systems and currency both in game
and if you want to spend real world
money on the game as well how all that
comes into play so he sees my potion
making equipment as evidence Gigi
welcome how's it going
fellow Social Club member right there
house rack and tour
what
but you had nothing to do with that
right
which by the way guys shout out to our
social club our social club so many of
us have been learning the game for the
first time and very quickly very quickly
you guys are picking it up and our
social club is doing amazing right now
top 100 which
I thought would be really difficult but
I should have known I should have known
you guys would rise to the occasion
you're right Falcon you know that you
just finished your two that's what I'm
trying to uh knock out today
oh we gotta sneak into filters office
but it should give us enough cover that
we can make it in unseen
but in order to do that we'll need some
tincture of Demi guys and pearl tincture
of dummy guys and pearl dust
oh do I already have some I think that's
what I went to get
dude you think that's what I picked up
in Diagon Alley I just kind of did it
handy ingredients to Daniel we I think
we already have them
were you able to get all the ingredients
sure
thanks I guess
no it's not turn-based combat
it is uh
it's car based combat which I haven't
played a lot of card games so I don't
know how it normally works but this one
it's like you've got your little
character and you can move around but
you can also you have like this meter
that's your magic points your MP and
whenever that fills you can throw out a
spell but each spell requires or summon
requires so many uh points to use and so
then that that meter goes back down so
if I've got like eight magic points and
I use a spell that's three it's gonna
drop down to five but then it'll
immediately start building back up again
we'll probably get into a battle here in
a second
you'll be able to see it okay use the
potion of invisibility
uh let's see renders the user invisible
for 30 minutes allowing one to sneak
into other houses common rooms used
during team exploration to skip straight
to the boss
guess I'm supposed to drink it right now
and then we gotta apparently sneak into
filch's office
oh I don't see him at all
I don't see Daniel at all
hide behind cover whenever possible
be careful and hide behind cover
whenever possible okay
is it like an open world exploration or
linear
so
it's it's
both like right now I'm just focusing on
the story which is very straightforward
and linear
but other than that it's like it's not
really it's not open world it's
definitely not open world
it's more like um
it's like an MMO style so like this
right here there's other people in here
like that's a real that's a real world
player you know right here
then this per like these are NPCs right
here this two these three are NPCs so
the people with the names on it those
are real world players but I'm like I'm
doing the story right now so I mean I
guess it's somewhat open like I could go
fly around Hogwarts right now we would
see we would see other real people
but then like once you're done with the
story there's all these other things to
keep doing like dueling club like
Forbidden Forest is kind of like this
little group activity Social Club has a
big group activity in it as well
all right let's talk to Lottie check on
Lottie I actually don't even know if
you're supposed to do that
[Music]
maybe I've never played Elder Scrolls
Online I have a buddy who was really
into that game but I never played I mean
the closest comparison I have for the
games I played is is Destiny but of
course Destiny is first person
but it is similar to that in terms of
like how there's a mixture of story and
a mixture of
things you can do with other people
eavesdrop on Robin and Kevin speaking of
the
blue you play ESO Alicia
well maybe Alicia can answer like is it
somewhat similar ESO in that regard if
you're not too busy on Saturday you can
try it out why are we eavesdropping on
people I don't understand
I suppose I could take a break Clash
Royale yes GG I heard somebody else
compare it to that
suppose I could take a break from
studying for picnic why don't we invite
everyone
my guy's waving he's invisible and he's
waving
you just started year two as well Ryan
nice
ESO is more open world okay gotcha
yeah it's like I mean this game is sort
of like
sort of opened
but definitely not open world you know
there are certain areas that are open
certain little hubs I guess you could
say
where you can see other people
it's hard to explain really yeah
Daniel's probably crying about his
confiscated cauldron right about now
the yellow ready
boy don't tell me you actually like
hmm
that would be stupid
you two
it's pathetic
I just love getting to know all the
characters though the NPCs in this game
they're so good
all the little story lines that you run
into
he's going to blow our cover come on
let's try to lose her oh we gotta try to
lose her
oh what
dude you can't operate filch
you're a Squibb
on no way
getting fish and chips oh my goodness I
just had fish and chips for lunch and it
was so good
oh we got a battlefields no way
wait what is Fields gonna do in a battle
Fields can't use Magic
oh he's got some kind of machine what is
this
or maybe this is gonna be
well it's gonna be a different uh
style of a gameplay than we've seen
before
oh defeat all red caps that's right
filch carries around the red caps after
using the invisibility potion you will
get a 10 second on combat starts okay
gotcha
the second simple
the witch snowballs
there we go
yeah we're so over leveled for the story
we're probably gonna just go through
everything pretty quickly
each year focuses on each character the
first year was Ivy second year is Lottie
night oh maybe maybe so
I love how we're still invisible
good timing Professor I caught these two
delinquents use it and we're still
invisible motion this is kind of awkward
my office
it's kind of awkward they true how do
they know once against me
it's not what happened we were just
trying to get my cauldron back after he
falsely accused me and confiscated it
right
and I'll fetch the chains professor
I can take things from here come with me
you too
you're invisible for like 20 minutes
after
so it's actually even after the story
like that section of the story ends oh
yeah we still are
that's too funny all right Slughorn I
trust they do need to
begin you learn fairly Daniel you have a
brilliant mind you're well brewed
invisibility potion proves that that's
why I'm gobsmacked you didn't think to
ask me or another professor for hemp
first
I don't know I suppose I was afraid
you'd think I was Daniel's story yeah I
think so too based on the trailer
I know better than to judge someone
based on their background you it's the
character of a person and how they use
their gifts that matter
I haven't taken the hair racing potion
yet
there are certainly gifted what remains
to be seen is how you'll use those gifts
I will speak to filch and see that your
potion making supplies are returned
straight away Daniel
but both of you have to serve a week oh
no
come on Slughorn
I won't let you down
all right talk to Daniel again okay
well that wasn't nearly as painful as I
thought it'd be still how Daniel how did
you get yours to wear off
we're still invisible
I should sneak into the other common
rooms
oh I bet it's funny yeah
clearly I don't need it either Daniel
we're still invisible here
you didn't tell us the secret
Cloud welcome in how's it going cloud
I should give it a go sometime
I feel like it the game's like come on
you know you want to
task received card primer Time Turner
head to the Great Hall all right before
we do that though
let's go
let's see
let's do Slytherin
try to sneak into the Slytherin common
room
oh Alicia I don't know that's a good
question
if you run out oh just
wait Social Club
does it take me to our social club oh it
does okay
oh by the way do you guys social club
members I made a new poster do you guys
see
I'm pretty proud of that
where is it Social Club poster here it
is this one right here
I was like this is us you guys this
represents all of us
all right so let's go back I want to see
if we can uh
the potion to run out
let's go back into Slytherin I want to
see what else you can do in there like
see if you can um
if there's any hidden items or anything
in there
all right stand up
what is he he walks oh no he walks
normal okay
can we like mess with people
oh wait what is that
why is it
why is it gold right there on the seat
it's got the little fireplace over here
oh look at the giant squid out there
no way they have it too
like Hogwarts Legacy oh man we've got
multiple squids look at that
multiple squids outside the common room
oh here's Ivy wait ivy
you're not a Slytherin what are you
doing in here
no way
Castle Corridor yeah the common rooms
it's not nearly like you can't explore
like you can in uh
in Legacy
see I don't even think it's not even
gonna let me leave this room is it
yeah just back into the castle corridor
you're able to sit oh it's places where
you can interact or sit okay
like wait what do you what do you push
you just tap it yeah there we go
Rejoice everyone who wanted sitting in
Hogwarts Legacy
there you go it is present in Magic
awakened
all right let's head to the Great Hall
still Invisible by the way
just sit there until it runs
we gotta we gotta get through the story
here
wait now Ivy you're already up here no
way
all right fine
let's see Ivy what are you up to
you started playing three days ago gold
at the moment with Hagrid locomotor
nice I mean I think the top I think the
current top player uses a hagra deck
from what I understand
you're a wizard Harry you're a wizard
Harry Mad Ducks hey thank you for
subscribing to the channel welcome in
appreciate it
nazarino how are you uh enjoying the
game so far are you liking it
I'm really into it
oh no they're messing with time
no don't do it that would be a recipe
for disaster
what do you think they were up to
anymore
something like that but more importantly
of what oh magana was like no no no no
no hold up hold up hold up
don't be talking about the time Turner
I know Gigi I agree
I agree being able to play with other
people
I just wish it didn't have like the
server limitations like I wanna I wish
we could play with Alicia
which I mean I guess you could
technically join on a different server
and I was saying it hasn't been too
laggy or anything for her
traveling back in time to undo it would
be less trouble than a simple deflating
draft is beyond me
just got a wife and two wait what
what rest assured I've set them straight
the Twins were not dare to game just
finished year two a few days ago
patiently waiting for your three have
they set like what's what's our uh time
frame do we know when your three is
going to be hitting
the twins will not be trying to reinvent
the time Turner as no one should
dangerous
oh come on retro are you really at
why are they so dangerous no way you're
asking that question time turn those are
actually quite safe it's when a witch or
wizard oh in Skyrim I gotcha that the
results can be catastrated
which is why the ministry of magic had
very strict regulations around as they
should
use a Time Turner and who could not
have you ever seen one
oh she has
it was approved to use a Time Turner a
few years ago
pretend you're in a DND Quest
it's a good story
oh please are we about to have one of
the yes
I love these moments
yes
we get to experience like some of the
iconic
moments from the original series
what's this one
Hermione and Snape
that's Snape right I'm pretty sure
yes
Professor snake
didn't even get a chance to read it
someone must have done this Snape did it
on purpose probably
we're still are we invisible as Hermione
no way right
defeat the spiders spiders are too far
away and I can't hit them okay so we're
going to use Time Turner someone your
future self Time Turner is Awesome by
the way using it in battle is really fun
to go where you can't your future self
will move with you and attack your
targets with basic attacks
it'd be a lot more powerful if they were
more than just basic attacks but
some might say it might be too powerful
there you go
well done
oh no we got more the d d stream this
Tuesday oh that's right
the spiders seem to have grown an awful
lot in a short amount of time could this
be the work of the time Turner
I have to deal with it now yes we will
as well as placing it at a distance from
yourself Time Turner can also be placed
near you to help you defend together
are you right here
work together
double Hermione's although I don't think
this is what they had in mind when they
gave you permission to use the time
Turner
yeah quidditch was originally in the
game okay let's see how do we want to do
this let's let you take on those two
and we'll deal with the two over here
gotta burn up those nice
but yeah they originally had quidditch
in the game and then I think Draco said
they had to take it out for something
and dared a game on sorry I missed your
comment there they haven't released your
three release date people are already
playing it in Japan what
no way
if you like Skyrim you'll love this game
for sure
yeah I do I love the animation I know
it's not some people don't don't love
the art style but I think it's great
getting to getting a different
perspective on The Wizarding World
well that was disappointing I was
thinking it was going to be a much
bigger moment than that with Hermione
what
there are limits to how far back you can
travel with a Time Turner silly
took it out to rework it okay gotcha
pixie and bomb box right so powerful
I'm with you McGonagall
don't need to be messing with time
reminds you of don't Don't Starve
Together I can see that a little bit
actually I played a lot of the first uh
Don't Starve
this one's certainly more colorful but
yeah I can definitely see the
similarities
all right talk to Ivy done
all right let's take a look at our
at our book here
oh man I was gonna try to finish this
today on stream but whew
it's gonna be gonna be tough actually
hold on did I unlock anything up here
yet nope not yet
when we complete 2-2 it looks like we'll
unlock that
which is coming up next
all right investigate the dungeons what
do we got in here
Robin and Kevin's Romance
no they have even
I've not played through chapter two yet
so
I don't think I've even picked up on it
click on the roads oh toads
[Music]
I'm still invisible
no way
all the things you said yeah Draco at
first I was like Rhodes what
on Earth do you tell them apart uh
because one of them smells worse
slightly smells
a painter has to pay attention to the
detail of her subjects
speaking of paintings where's gosma love
the art style and apparently there is
some okay wait so it wasn't just me Gigi
yet
that's funny ghost
oh gossamer almost forgot about you
adventured far to find me I hope it
wasn't too dangerous
there he is
magical me
yes dare to Game On Ike my son has been
trying to play
and I think it's something to do with
the age that you set when you start the
game
he was trying to play on iPad and he got
that glitch and he can't leave he can't
leave the first room
all he can do is duel and that's it
so that's a big one
a radical radical with the Super Chat
thank you so much I love a tri-wizard
tournament game
that would be pretty cool
you thinking like in the Hogwarts Legacy
style or would you want to see it more
something like this
I feel like that one you'd want like a
Hogwarts Legacy style but thank you so
much for the Super Chat appreciate it
wait let's do
atmosphere Charlie
I haven't like built any decks strictly
for Pb
PVE at all I've been like all my deck
building this is like my PVP stuff right
now but it works
Pixies versus Pixies let's go
yo radical Z with another Super Chat
let's go thank you so much radical in
the Hogwarts Legacy style like a DLC
maybe yeah see if Hogwarts Legacy did it
well any anybody who does uh Triwizard
the thing they would have to figure out
is when they're like the time frame
to make it make it work with the the
lore so Hogwarts Legacy would have to go
back like even further
to hit the right time frame but yeah try
wizard that has been a very popular
request
from a lot of people
[Music]
what can I do for you
we're looking for a map that leads to a
rare magical artifact Hagrid said that
one of the paintings might know where to
find it
hmm I've never heard of this I thought
you knew everything about the paintings
in Hogwarts
mostly everything
I can only sniff around so much I only
have one nose
that's the portraits in the dungeons
would know something
Maybe
[Music]
troll you have to find them dude if we
don't fight a troll in the dungeon
what a missed oh
I said nothing's down there that can
hurt us
gotta be a troll in the dungeon come on
what happened to the the Quidditch
Champions game it's still coming
yeah they did a series of play tests so
I think they've done three
so yeah they're still working on it
I nominate me afraid of
in case you need me
radical with another Super Chat this
time a five dollar Super Chat radical my
friend thank you so much uh radical Z
back to back to back super chats here
and Hogwarts Legacy too what locations
would you want to see that we haven't
yet diagonally or Ministry of magic or
Grandma Place Ministry of magic for sure
for sure
Ministry magic would be awesome
I know a big one people want like other
Wizarding World schools
[Music]
I'll wait till they finish talking here
and then uh radical also sub into the
channel thank you radical
headless
oh they're having it's nearly headless
Nick's death day party
I did get run yeah
he's really good
really good
so Nicholas I'm afraid we don't have an
invitation to your party but we would
love to celebrate with you if you'll
have us of course after much
consideration I've decided that you and
your friends can attend one condition I
bet we need to go get something for him
oh no okay okay
need to make party hats all right
the doorman oh yeah yes this nasty truck
ah there is a troll in the dungeon
you knew you knew they had to do a troll
in the dungeon Roger what's up welcome
in Roger security and he comes charging
right here but no need to worry about
that now oh Ron and Draco those are
those are both
those are two really good ones
we're gonna get to fight him aren't we
Nick's just out of there come on Nick he
can't even hurt you yes trolling the
dungeon
it's all chilled a new
took out the bomb that quick oh wait you
know what does Ivy work on him let's see
there's nothing I did let's see
oh he shoved us back atmosphere
that would have been too easy
it works in PvP
oh he's got quite a bit of Health
doesn't he
oh he's about to take out my niff
ah a troll taking out a niffler not
something I ever thought I would see
in a Harry Potter game but there we go
hey this Troll's got a lot of Health
go Pixies
use the bombs
atmosphere
I got my Bellatrix echo on
let's see if we get this all the way
before beating him
Mrs racket tour in the chat as well
I think Luna wants out Mrs raconteur
you're fine just relax
but um I love what cloud said about
I think I think Hogwarts Legacy 2 would
have to be
Hogwarts still has to be a central part
of it obviously but going to London
would be really cool
we talked about this in a couple live
streams I've done like a four hour live
stream on this channel where we just
really did a deep dive breakdown of
Hogwarts Legacy a deep dive review
we talked about it some there
and then we also talked about it on a
live stream with the expecto go where we
just we really
get in deep
radical C with another five dollar Super
Chat oh my goodness radical
oh there he showed up Kevin
let's go
wait
there's there's our little romance
there's a little hug
I don't know who's going to watch the
door actually you know what
oh dude this is a this is actually
genius
to anybody watching this in the replay
I'm sorry for talking over some of the
dialogue to this point whenever I do the
the more kind of story based streams
like this that's always one of the
complaints people like please stop
talking over the game
I'm sorry but we got radical here with
the donations you know
so this is actually a perfect feature
the fact that I can pause it radical
thank you so much for that five are you
gonna watch the Harry Potter TV show oh
yeah I'll definitely watch it it'll be
more faithful to the books from the
sound of it which sounds promising yeah
a lot of people were just kind of like
no we don't need it which I wouldn't
have picked that like that would have
been my first choice
if you said hey let's make a new Harry
Potter TV series I wouldn't have said
let's remake The Originals that wouldn't
have been my top pick however I'm
definitely open to it and we'll and
we'll watch it because I think there's a
lot of opportunity
to like you said to make it more
faithful than the movies
and you know it's not gonna like replace
the movies that's the biggest thing like
people were like oh it's you know this
will erase my childhood memory I'm like
no no you'll still have those you can go
back and watch them anytime
radical CEO
radical Z IA with another Super Chat a
two dollar Super Chat here Harry Potter
TV show could lead to spin-offs
absolutely and and there was also that
rumor
I wouldn't call it a leak I guess it was
more like a rumor that they were gonna
make a Hogwarts Legacy TV show
which would have been really interesting
like I would pick that over remaking the
Harry Potter stuff maybe people got
confused and the Harry Potter movie
remake is actually what
it ended up being but I mean something
set in the time period of Hogwarts
Legacy focusing maybe on one of the
teachers
now she wants back in here she can't
make up her mind you guys she just can't
make up her mind
what is wrong
she can't make up her mind all right
let's see what Nick's got to say here
it's down here in the dungeon it's a
good idea we need to make sure all the
paintings are on the list carry on I
must see to the punch not a moment of
ways
still Invisible by the way still still
invisible you know what like we can just
shout out has anyone seen a map leading
to a secret treasure
a lady never tells a lady
no you're too clothed who the heck are
you lady oh yeah Marauder spin-off would
be awesome
for the founders
give me the founders
because she kept ordering Wizards to get
her tea that's such a sad story she must
have lost people she loved
lady
the map it leads to a family heirloom
that was lost we'd like to find it and
give it back
what about our homework
I am what about our homework she's like
come on
have a little sympathy
yeah I think most people would cloud
Mrs Norris
again I was surprised to see she's still
alive in this game
it after they moved me to this Dreadful
local Ten Years After
Harry's seventh year
Mrs Norris got to be getting up there
maybe there's some magical uh
I'm not sure magical effects going on
there
where are all the where are all the
ghosts
always complaining about the noise are
we just way early for the death day
party
Nicholas
so where you'll go and do make sure
you're back with all the party starts
oh we were just early okay he said have
her back before the party starts
this is more like it a home that suits
my stature wonderful now what can you
tell us about the map
I think I'm afraid because I've never
seen it
but I know who has my old neighbors
talked about the man so where are these
old neighbors of yours
dude these cutscenes are pretty long
actually
can you describe this bad neighbor
whenever he comes to
hops on about a dark secret chamber full
of carvings oh no
Chamber of Secrets
[Music]
I think I've heard of that secret
chamber I've got an art book that talks
all about the paintings Trisha you could
be right
place is nearly impossible to find oh
let's go
yes
enemies of the air beware
GG no I noticed that too for a game that
has so many of the Spells
yeah what's up with that no Patronus in
Hogwarts Legacy or this game
task received sectum simpra head to the
castle Corridor and we just unlocked a
golden key we'll make sure we redeem
that before the end of the stream today
all right let's go on to the castle
corridor
radical appreciate it thank you so much
appreciate those super chats today glad
you found the channel and you subscribed
thanks for stopping by
yeah we got a lot of Hogwarts Legacy
videos here on the channel and more
recently a lot of magic awaken videos on
the channel
that's odd where's all this water coming
from I better go and investigate inspect
the puddle on the floor oh here we go
dude you guys know where this hey we're
finally Not Invisible
can I not control the camera there we go
Jenny welcome in uh
maybe a DLC with the getting Patronus
I would love to see that
that's that's my pick
for oh when they were you were just
asking radical I I forgot that one
Azkaban Azkaban for a Hogwarts Legacy
DLC
where we learned the Patronus charm yes
yes that would be awesome
I'm moaning metal
Draco there will be a Patronus spell
card oh wait here she is dude here she
is
have they already confirmed that
Patronus is coming to Magic awaken
that's awesome
oh dude
here we go did I try the green potion
yet wait which one
potions is definitely one of the things
that I haven't experimented with enough
hair raising no I have not tried that
one yet unless it was I think it might
have been required at one point
or do we have to use it I think we had
to use it in a battle or something but
that's the only time I used it
all right let's see what moaning
Myrtle's up to
what do you want come to laugh at
miserable
oh you used it on any the other
what is
Twan server
no
yeah we we just did that earlier about
sneaking into the common room
the phrase of course
and I wonder you're so upset I'd flood
the bathroom too if someone did that to
me
don't pretend like you care about me no
one ever cares oh Myrtle all these years
later
underneath
since Draco Draco I can wait a moment
Draco as in Draco Malfoy
yes Kindred Spirits he and I
did at home
but a sensitive Soul who just wanted to
be oh she's in love with Draco
didn't he try to assassinate the
previous Headmaster
oh my gosh the ads again
Roger no
I thought I turned that off this time
yes didn't he try to assassinate the
Headmaster she said technically yes
all right Moaning Myrtle let's hear
let's hear you attempt to uh
make it out so Draco was not a bad guy
in all this
let's hear it
oh we're getting to actually see it
all because it's sectum sempra that's
right
oh there's Harry
is this why you've been so secretive
oh we're gonna get to fight it out
flashback Harry versus Draco no way
sector launches attacks that can bounce
between multiple opponents dude where'd
Draco get
Drago's just called out some centaurs
here
how dare you oh he's mad
oh draco's got the trolls on us
all right come on Ivy
yeah there we go that's how it's
supposed to work
Dude where's the music I feel like we
should have music did it glitch out or
something
you won
you got a vodka diver and Caruso at the
same time what is that even possible in
this game
that's like the greatest odds ever if
that happened
[Music]
to be fair Draco was rather nasty to
hurry wasn't he see retro knows the
story retro knows not to mention that
Draco did attack first
dang
Myrtle's defending hard
I think so
I don't think so I am
the Harry Potter you such horrible dark
magic and against a fellow student well
he didn't know yet
but I never forgive Harry you got crucio
Trisha no way
I've heard it's incredible in the
Forest
man I want that scene from the trailer
don't don't tell me guys don't tell me
if and or when it happens
but I want to get to relive the Chamber
of Secrets moment oh dude and we got
another sectum semper card let's go
all right talk to Daniel in the entrance
Courtyard
scintillation solution
you're a wizard Harry you're a wizard
Harry
J gaming with the sub thank you so much
Jay welcome in
hope you're having a good day here we
are just hanging out right now playing
Harry Potter magic awaken in chapter two
making our way through the story without
cheating
and yet I did so unless you've got some
proof to back up those bogus claims I
suggest you get to work on our potions
essays oh dang and no big words don't
take that from them Daniel don't take it
here let's go cheer him up
tell them not to take that anymore we
got us back
you went to add it to your deck and it
was like are you sure
I was wondering are there any negative
consequences for using a
because I noticed the same thing I was
just gonna play around with Avada
Kedavra
because I got that one
I can't pause it right now
but yeah I gotta vodka driver I'm just
gonna try it out and I got that same
message it's like are you sure
Mike is this gonna affect the story
somehow
no so in addition to being totally
in front of the entire dueling Club
s homework for a week nah Daniel come on
you
no says uh hello world not yet anyway
true true
that'd be crazy if it actually ended up
affecting something later down the line
up to something if you're that convinced
then how can I help
I don't think I ever set up the lurk
here Jenny but appreciate you being here
sounds good thanks for letting me know
that's what you were worried about
Trisha so you didn't add it yeah
keep an eye out for anything suspicious
okay
follow the phrase to the library
to the library we go
interact
Madame pins wait we got we had two two
sets of dialogue going there
now Alicia it's just like people letting
the streamer know that they're still
here supporting the stream as a viewer
but they're not they're not going to be
active in chat
it's just like a just like a heads up
I have no proof that it's ours
right they're definitely cheating
should we tell Professor Flitwick
dude this is like the question on
Wizarding World do you guys remember the
Sorting
the question about
the homework and do you turn them in do
you tell them actually I think that one
said a friend though
true or maybe just a fellow classmates
in that question
also we gotta go find some evidence
back to the bathroom okay
talk to Daniel again now investigate the
bathroom
back to the bathroom we go
okay what are we supposed to do look
around for
evidence oh search for their potion
trying to turn the camera around
oh I think we got it
waiting for the third year yes uh I've
heard a lot of people are looking
forward to it
Daniel reminds you of Sebastian
sometimes
how so like in his uh
the sparkling turquoise I don't know I
don't know if I see Sebastian
he doesn't seem as
dark Sebastian
it's a potion that boosts your
proficiency and Intel
intelligence Alicia I love Daniel hate
Seb this is awkward
it's no wonder fish a phrase on a
winning streak he was already a pretty
talented to do this before been cheating
with potion huh
it seems to be master
the only question now is what we're
going to do about it
oh no here we go
tell Flitwick sabotage their Brew swap
out their potion
oh my goodness
okay what would I do this is real if I
was really in this situation
oh man this is my first I don't remember
any choices like this before
I don't feel like tell Flitwick would
end well
sabotage their Brew
I think swap out their potion
yeah Dylan that's that's what I'm
leaning to
I'm leaning to swap zodiac by the way
what's up welcome in
racing swapped I agree
yes I do have a bottle of pumpkin juice
on me that we could pass off as a fake
potion
a simple color changing charm and
they'll never know the difference
Daniel seems more like ominous I could
see that a bit
excuse me sir
excuse me hello
what was that
oh man that was so funny Shadow Drake
Shadow Drake wanting a little screen
time on the stream today
oh man that was great
find the phrase at the entrance
Courtyard okay
[Laughter]
right
this dude's just over there we're just
like having a conversation
personal space indeed right
all right I bet we're gonna
already did the duel
actual stream sniper maybe who knows
see if they figure it out
it was Bloody useless potion see we're
totally
we're totally in the clear
totally in the clear like now they don't
even they just think the potion wasn't
that great
yes all right so is anybody in the chat
has anyone picked the other options if
so how did it go down
because so far I mean who knows we'll
see if anything else happens but that
that went as smooth as it as it could go
I think
yo yo it's your boy James expecto go
what is up man welcome in no
no I'm gonna go tell them to write their
own stupid everybody say hello I feel
like most of you in the chat already
know our buddy James
if not
check out his channel man check out
expecto go over on YouTube lots of magic
awakened content lots of magic awaken
streams
all right let's see what we got okay
what's next here
James what have you been up to man what
have you been up to
I I have a question for James you guys I
have a big important question
hold on I Gotta Go full cam for this
actually
all right
all right James
I gotta know something man I gotta know
how
did you let me sleep on this game
how did you let me sleep on this game
oh my goodness how'd you let me sleep on
this
I think Cindy was in the chat the other
day we were streaming on Twitch and she
was like yeah we've all we've been
saying how much fun I'm like why didn't
anybody tell me and then Draco was in
the chat draco's like I tried to tell
you retro
Christy what is up no no you didn't
catch the end you just caught a moment
where I had to reach out to James and
say come on man
oh man no but like I've been so
pleasantly surprised by this game you
guys like James has played a lot of
mobile games a lot more than I have
so
James played the um
whatever you call it like the soft
launch period which a lot of people were
playing in the soft launch but I don't
know I just like never
I just like I didn't I didn't think it
was this big I didn't think there was
this much to do
but man is it good
you're talking about this games it's
yeah I feel like it was always just kind
of like a footnote for me
it's like oh yeah there's that because
we've been you know we talked all the
time about on the joint live streams
like man they need to do an MMO they
need to do an MMO guys this is an MMO
like this play with your friends go to
Hogwarts together
classes like the daily life as a student
they nailed it
they nailed it and they also like
I I actually think I like
oh man I can't believe I'm saying this I
can't believe I'm saying this
I like that it has a mobile component I
like the game to be clear the game is
fully like fully playable on mobile
because like
it's like I play for a while and then
I'm in bed at night it's like oh man you
know what I could do just one more duel
this actually might be a bad we were
saying I was saying on Twitch this
actually might be a bad thing
but it's like oh you know what I'm
traveling I need to hop in and do my
dailies wait I can play on my phone I
still wish it would come to console and
I'm still looking forward to the uh like
full PC release but I mean like imagine
imagine this
like if I was making my ideal Harry
Potter MMO I'm like what would I really
what would I change about this
I do love the art style but I think I
would like to see you know better
graphics overall I think would be nice
well we gotta fly to go talk to Lottie
here
oh man
and you guys already know like I love
like I like playing on a controller so
give me give me controller support but
be good
although like mouse and keyboard is
perfect for the uh
the style of this game I was telling my
son the other day you know what I think
is the best
I think the best experiences experience
we're playing this game might be on like
iPad or something
because you get you get a nice big
screen
but then you can like because playing
this on the phone oh my goodness I mean
and I have a small phone I have the uh
iPhone Mini so my screen is is Tiny and
all these little buttons and extra stuff
here it gets so crowded
but the iPad you got that nice big
screen then you got you can you know
touch and move everything around so
we're trying to get it to where my
oldest can play on the iPad but he's I
was telling the chat earlier he's got
the bug right now where you can't you
can't progress past the
the first little like when you first get
to your common room he can't get out all
he can do is do a Duo duel and that's it
we'll let him out
so I'm hoping that at some point
they'll patch it they haven't done an
update Metatron you like playing on the
iPad
do you have to be connected to the
internet to play
I'm pretty sure that is a yes Lauren I'm
pretty sure you have to be connected
online to play
no we haven't dueled we have not done
any kind of duels yet
the reception has been incredible it
really has and I mean apparently it was
number one on Google Play it was number
one on iOS we'll see how long it hangs
on iOS the reviews were insanely
positive it had like over I was looking
at it yesterday let's see what it is now
it had over 11 000 votes or something
and it was five stars
let's see what it is now Harry Potter
magic awake and yeah it's fifteen
thousand
votes now
4.7 overall
right now it's number two in role
playing second only to
what second to age of apes
yeah age of Apes man gotta gotta knock
them off the top spot
oh that's too funny
yeah but there's so many things we're
gonna be able to do content-wise with
this game expect to go versus retro what
no we got we gotta team up
don't don't pit don't pit James and I
against one another
we're the dynamic duo here we gotta we
gotta do some Duo duels rank up to the
top
and expect to go with the Super Chat hey
James thanks so much for the five James
says uh what has been your favorite Echo
and card so far oh yeah good question
for everybody in the chat too and smash
the like button thank you James
appreciate it yeah so so far
I was like Hermione is the one that I
played the most by far just overall
and in this in the solo duels pretty
much got me through
bronze silver and
a lot of gold
and then yesterday we were streaming on
Twitch and several top level
dual players started popping into the
stream I don't know how I guess they
just go around looking to give other
people advice or something so they
started giving me some tips and stuff
and talking to me about the Bellatrix
deck
so I switched over to Bellatrix and at
first like we were doing on I played her
a little bit on stream and I was like
hey I'm not really feeling it
ended the stream yesterday and we were
at like 25
I can't remember what exactly we were at
but we were still like 500 or something
off of
getting to platinum
and then I hopped on once we got the
kids in bed hopped on to play a little
bit more and I was like let me give this
Bellatrix deck a try one more try and I
kind of swapped a couple cards out
and I just started like ripping ripping
through the ranks we got we got all the
way to platinum had a couple win streaks
along the way to
so right now like for PVP wise I've been
going with uh with Bellatrix a lot
although I know the Newt spam the Newt
spammers are very very powerful
but yeah then I'm still kind of working
on my my PVE deck I guess you would call
it the deck that I want to use for when
I'm just just playing like forest and
stuff this spell right here is crazy
though
Weasley's Wildfire whiz-bangs now you
got to get everything grouped together
that spell puts out ridiculous damage it
also has a very high cost so that's why
using it with somebody like Hermione is
preferable because you get that cost
down all right so for Echo I'll say I'll
say Hermione because I played Hermione
the most
and then a spell that I've only recently
been
exposed to is aguamenti right here
aguaminti in the forest you guys
do not underestimate this spell
aguaminty is is insane
it is so good
so so good
that's right sorry I'm catching up on
the comments yeah James did reach out
and we're gonna try to uh set up
something with with somebody else yeah
Metatron you like playing on the iPad
yeah I feel like the iPad is like the
perfect place to play it dancing on PC
is incredibly difficult Alicia it is
doable to a point there are some that
you get to that I don't see how anybody
would be able to do it on PC
which is why I'm curious if the official
PC client changes anything up
if anybody's playing in another country
and you have the official PC client in
your area
let me know is the dancing minigame any
different
because the dancing minigame the way it
starts out
you can you can just click like the
first couple levels they're easy you can
just click click the little bubbles no
problem but then you start getting up to
level three and definitely by level four
then you start getting somewhere you
have multiple bubbles on screen at once
you got one on one side one on the other
and there's just no way you could do it
with a mouse
then you start having some that are
level fives
you talk about ramping up in difficulty
the
the level 5 dances
incredibly hard
they introduced totally new mechanics
all of a sudden you're having to like
drag your finger and connect these dots
it's it's insane
also we had a new subscriber in there
let's see who was that that subscribed
I missed a subscriber in there welcome
to the channel calm or cold but not sure
how to pronounce it c-o-l-b Ryan you've
been playing on iPad as well nice Ginny
you've been playing on iPad but your
iPad's really old and crashes oh darn it
Tracy you just ordered an iPad you're
most excited to play this game on it
when it come I'm getting a new phone
this year when the new iPhone comes out
I've had this one it'll be two years so
I'm like I'm gonna go with a bigger
screen this time
and I'm looking forward to playing a
magic awakened on it
Draco that's right Draco you bought an
iPad just for uh didn't you say just to
play this or something
GG you have one of the oldest iPads
yours from 2016 still the biggest thing
you have I mean hey I feel like that as
long as it runs the game well
I feel like that'd be solid
Don't Be Afraid oh about the duels nah I
would duel I would I would do I would do
duels too if we wanted to but I think
it'd be fun to do the Duos as well
we could have like whole
I don't know I need to talk to you James
but I just I don't know I feel like if
we had like a day where we both stream
together and just you know run forest
run duels I think that'd be a lot of fun
Hermione Echo with thunderstorm and
Avada cadaver I've not used a lot of of
I haven't used a vodka kadaver at all
yet I have it right here believe it or
not it was like one of the very first I
guess technically it's called a dark
card and not a legendary but it was one
of the very first ones I got I couldn't
believe it
I wanted CR I mean I hear crucios a lot
better though so
yeah Russ I have it's been uh it's been
difficult at times you know trying to
trying to find the right kind of Lane to
go down because there's so many
different
so many different paths we could take
the channel
and some days I you know magic awaken
has given us kind of a a clear thing to
focus on
but yeah it's been uh in some ways it's
been harder than I expected for sure in
some ways it's been
certain challenges that you don't expect
but yeah it's
it's definitely been fun
Harry with snowball is a perfect pair
yeah Harry is kind of a fun deck too
because you can play it with um
you know just spec it out with a lot of
the lower level cards and they're just
gonna do ridiculous damage
brother 86 with this game last long
I think this game has big time staying
power
big time staying power now James James
might be able ex I should call you
expect to go in the chat so people
so people know expect to go might be a
better person to ask about that because
expect to go played a ton of
Harry Potter wizard Unite
I don't think he played as much of the
other one Hogwarts mystery I know he
played it some
and then I know he's played a lot of
this and know he's played a lot of other
mobile games so
I don't really know what they look for I
mean obviously at the end of the day
it's money right if this game continues
to make money it will continue to be
here for a long long time
but like Hogwarts mystery is still going
match um
oh my gosh Wizards unite Unfortunately
they ended up shutting it down
because it I guess they just didn't have
enough of a consistent player base and
it wasn't making enough money I I don't
know
so I mean I already feel like I've I've
heard about this way more than Hogwarts
mystery which Hogwarts mystery is still
oh and there's puzzles and spells too
forgot about puzzles and spells that's
actually a really fun really fun uh
little uh match three game I love that
game
but but I mean like if they can get
somebody like me interested
I was telling my wife she's a nurse and
has a ton of friends at work who who
bought consoles just to play Hogwarts
Legacy
and see it's like if they can tap into
those people because they're this game
like I know a lot of us it's all we've
been talking about and thinking about
lately but there is still a huge number
of people
who don't know about this game Harry
Potter magic awaken
but when you tell those people like like
those nurses that hey you could play
this game on your phone
all those people who were so pumped for
Hogwarts Legacy and it's like if you
enjoyed that but maybe you want more of
like that kind of student experience if
you want more of that experience being
able to play with your friends you
really need to check out this free to
play game Harry Potter magic awakened so
that was a very long answer for you
brother but yeah I definitely think it
has has some staying power for sure
thunderstorm is always a band card oh
really people ban that one
Bella apparently is huge in The Meta oh
no James you're you're a newt oh man
the new when when you get when you go up
against a newt
that has like
they're creatures all over
I'll say on from going against a lot of
them one of the most frustrating things
to go against
Hagrid's can be too but I I feel like I
don't know there's something about Newt
that feels
that like makes me rage being on the
other end of it it makes me rage
Hermione Echo with crucio oh is it
pretty powerful
Draco says it is different on PC
I want to know how it's different
Jenny you got an iPad Mini from 2015
does it play it pretty well
oh wait hello world says my version has
to press like five buttons
the arrows the arrows
in spacebar at an incredible speed oh my
gosh
Dylan hey thanks for being here Dylan
Dylan has been our just
Dylan started out our social club and is
consistently at the top of our our
social club points Dylan has been
putting in a lot of time on this game
Jenny play puzzle and spells Hogwarts
Mysteries too slow waiting for energy
yeah that's kind of what I heard too
okay so here's expecto goes answer about
like the staying power money is the
driving force of course for all mobile
free to play games it's Atop The sales
in the uh
SCA Market oh my goodness Southeast Asia
just need the Western markets to buy
into it which I think it will I think so
too man I think so too
Gigi you play puzzles and spells every
day
no way
new for the win oh man
Newt Newt man they're tough to deal with
they are tough to deal with
fiend fire is really fun too I don't
have fiend fire yet
but look at this you guys I just noticed
as we were talking here I am at 70 out
of 75 cards right now
that is
that's really awesome
and five are the ones that I don't have
crucio for sure Pier totem locomotor oh
man I should have bought that card last
night but I didn't want to spend all
those coins it was 20 000 coins and I
was sitting at about thirty thousand or
no I was sitting at twenty thousand
could have used gyms to get up to thirty
thousand but I was like man I'm gonna
need these to upgrade so I'm just
holding out hope that I'll get it
get it here soon
all right well that was a fun little
discussion guys let's see what Lottie
has for us here as we continue to press
on through the story so we are at
chapter
2-2 right now almost to 2-3
so let's hit backer here go ahead and
talk to Lottie
oh it freezes on your iPad Jenny
and that was from about 2015.
have you seen my SketchBook
clearing in the Forbidden Forest I was
doing a bit of sketching out that way I
could have sworn I put it back in my bag
when I finished
but it's not there
on the ashwinder server dragon egg is
meta healing spell yeah I ran into
somebody trying to use that a lot
so long as we're in the general area we
can use the summoning charm to bring it
right to us
the best counter for the egg is
atmospheric charm
put atmospheric charm on it it has like
a debuff or something for heels
gives you time to get up another spell
so if you get if you have like ins if
you have atmospheric charm and then like
incendio boom you can take it out
all right cast accio with the designated
spot I actually don't think I have any
accio cards yet are we going to get a
free accio for this
would be awesome if we did
oh all good Jenny sounds good
you're in Southeast Asia nice welcome in
appreciate you stopping by and hanging
out today hope you're enjoying the
Stream
thank you sketch boot there it is
do I have accio yet or not actually I
can't remember if I have it yet what
happened
apparently I only need five spells
and I know at least two of them are
legendary
oh no we said the wrong thing
that's right you can't be saying die
again Ally
look at my Sketchbook there to quickly
do little cute fairy that was flattering
by
all right another accio
let's try this again
Akio SketchBook
wait did it still not
interesting somebody took your
Sketchbook no way
what am I doing wrong I've read that you
have to clearly visualize the object
you're trying to sell oh my gosh maybe
it's just not here Lottie
yes all right no I was thinking about
that sketch you did of a unicorn last
week can I try one last time it's a
matter of Pride now
of course but let's move over to that
stump I remember setting my bag down on
it as I packed up all my art supplies
it's possible my Sketchbook fell out
while I was rounding up my pencils
all right third time's the charm maybe
let's see
over here
don't worry Lottie I've got a good
feeling about this time oh accio body
SketchBook
oh
how did I know they were gonna have
something to do with it
don't look too happy at being found out
defeat The Fray twins
why does it do that sometimes there's
like a little delay
we're starting the battle
all right I think we're going in
the phrase look angry
they look very angry and protect Lottie
and defeat all opponents oh my goodness
they're already sending out the Monster
books
uh David Weaver thank you for
subscribing to the channel welcome in
oh I do have accio I've just never used
it before
I recognize the card now the last ended
screwed is a ranged attacker that
doesn't move use accio to pull it within
range to attack
wait it didn't work oh we just
we defeated it like oh I think it was
just okay
maybe it's just showing me how to use it
oh we did not mean to use it on you
well we switch decks
or did they have a give us a different
deck for this
man incendio is so good
the frey twins escaped
wait what I didn't even know I was I
thought we wanted to drive them away
isn't that what we wanted to do
i z Subs how's it going welcome in
curious about any Hogwarts Legacy DLC I
mean oh if I knew about I know nothing
man I hope so though I definitely hope
so
I still feel like it's gonna happen it's
just a matter of when
and it seems that they're kind of
content right now to just be working on
the switch on the switch version so
maybe next year I'm hoping early next
year
you follow Lottie all the way store
Sketchbook why yeah why did you take it
like it'd be fun
no way what do we care about some stupid
George you drew the first loyalty oh she
drew them
yes
I'm ending with a more abstract
post-modern style I didn't realize that
so I play
WWB or Garena
I'm not sure what that means
is that server I'm on the opal I server
I had no idea my art hurts you I should
have considered how you'd feel before I
drew it how about I rip this one up and
start over
suppose I can't stop you
I suppose I can't stop it I want to
thank you for helping me find my sketch
up want to thank you retro
you're welcome Lottie you gonna draw me
now
all right knock that one out
chapter 3 enter the chamber
no way
I'm ready to enter the chamber
I guess I should have to change the
title of the video
what I meant was year two
weird Wizarding dilemmas and their
Solutions oh man I'm I think there'd be
something about
I'm so excited for this
not great I just picked the book with
the best art on the cover
oh what if it's not in a book
everything's in a book
I don't know is the Chamber of Secrets
in a book probably not I have a few
strategies
in beating the bludgers a study of
defensive strategies and quidditch right
if we're being chased by a bludger
I feel like we're so close to finding
the next clue to the map
so many books in here
like the answer to the problem is just
going to jump out at us
of course
wait a pug no
wait what no
okay I was thinking did they mess up
no she actually
didn't know what a pug no does
okay let's take out this one
hey I got some Monster books too
go get him
oh my gosh
we gotta take out this big one over here
we're gonna die
no we cannot die in the story
we cannot die in the story
no
stop it
we need Ron
we've almost got him
oh I should have I should have waited
for the Dragon
come on we're so close to getting Ron
out once we get run it's all over
yes
wait run no
Ron come on dude
you didn't drop out oh wait this is
recommended level 33 no way
I'm not even level 33 yet entering
battle please wait for a moment
oh my goodness
all right this is actually tough
[Music]
I'm not gonna put the niffler out
because they're just gonna
okay now
Cassandra should be good for this
all right this time I'm just gonna wait
until I get the dragon it's the ant
bedina opal eye should be
there we go
or enterpodian as they say in this
come on opal I destroy them
yes the opal eye is ripping through them
right now
now go get the big one
all right now Ron there he goes
oh my God she's huge
why is this little book oh dude I guess
this is just the level difference
I may not be able to do any future
sections until I level up a little bit
more
we made it
Roger this is just about where you're at
Timothy ninja welcome in dude welcome
expressing himself
I bet this is what your room looks like
on Kevin no my books are organized in a
much more geometric Matrix
see Roger have a good one dude
okay you can finish your two at this
level nice
boy who lived
Harry Potter yes
we gotta find somebody who can speak
parcel tongue first of all
fascinating it's just like the boys
toilets
took you forever to level up for the
last boss
be at least 33. gotcha
[Music]
he doesn't haunt the bathroom because
she has a weak bladder
oh my goodness
so your average haunted murder bathroom
is going to hide in here did I say hide
come on Kevin you got this
he keeps trying it eventually makes it
easier
oh no
she's not happy
get
something finished and leave so I can
cry
mid man what's up level 29 year 2-5 okay
nice but we should be good
at least until the end
all about the strategy that's right
[Music]
you know where it is
I can draw a picture of all of us
oh Nick I'm so excited I'm ready to go
in there
why do you want a picture with Kevin
why do you care
um
Myrtle calling her out
well Myrtle picked up on it even if we
didn't guys
have you ever thought about that do
ghosts appear in portraits in Harry
Potter
I guess so
because she wants to get a picture can
you tell that's where the chamber is
it's right here under the sink
there must be a command impossible time
oh
fire oh
is that close
come on why isn't it opening
Myrtle in this version really scares you
oh
she does feel even a bit more unhinged
in this game
thank you
anything for you Kevin
oh I think she did she just whisper it
to him
nope that's not right Kevin
that's not right
oh yeah come on retro step up there
it's like this guys
to use the story mode voice feature
Harry Potter magic waking requires
access to your microphone nah I'm just
gonna do it normally
I don't even think I have my mic
connected
side
oh my gosh
open Chamber of Secrets
can you identify my voice now
if not then I don't think I have the mic
set up ah okay that's fine
yeah we'll skip that step
foreign
there we go Kevin you got it
if you don't get killed in the chamber
come back and see me
well the Basilisk shouldn't be there
anymore
it's post Harry Potter's day
so it's just gonna be a little bit
creepy
oh dude
this is so fun
if you need to destroy a horcrux
there you go Kevin
come on is this the moment where we get
come on come on come on I want to relive
the memory let's go
let us relive the memory
that's right I forgot about the portrait
yo hello yeah right what a lot we have
here the name is basil Ardent or radius
III misplaced wizard gentleman scholar
can't you just travel your portrait
password was different for you
oh that's interesting
foul Musk
what no I mean are you a friend of Lady
Princess Patrick Goggins going to purge
the world of Lady portraits you
you're goundrels
we're not going to purge the world of
anything
just a map
you have the wrong secret chamber
how many secret places are there in this
no
passage but the only person who knows
where that passage is is our dear friend
Harold who sadly left Hogwarts some time
ago before I ended up down here in fact
that must be the third painting lady
Goggins was talking about
exactly
where did he go oh I wasn't I wasn't
saying that hello world Gigi was saying
that hers was a different password in
the chat there
he's at the hogshead Inn
oh I'm always at the hog's head it's
what Dumbledore's
sounds like a fun place
there's another member of your little
huh over there
whoa
Society is over here
who is this
excuse me what
who are you
oh my goodness no way
fantastic
Cornish Pixies go get him fighting a
basilisk with Pixies
one of the things that I love about this
game man monster book
this is not even the deck that I meant
to be playing with but we're just gonna
make it work
s you're a wizard Harry David and Malik
welcome in guys thank you all for
subscribing to the channel here
hope you're having a good day so far
well we gotta get out of this poison
though
all right let's get Cassandra out to
help
put an incendio right there
and then I'm gonna save up for the
dragon here
Actually I don't even think we need the
dragon but
should make it end even faster
nice
fantastic bomb
must be a Slytherin yeah
fight you coward
ly nice shoes there's only one way into
this place right so that means there's
only one way out
do we do that
after him
Pete how's it going welcome in
appreciate you stopping by
yeah we are doing well hope you're
having a a good day
glad you got to stop by and say hello oh
it's this professor
Stargazer Tim
with the 10 months
oh there's the
hold on can I pause it right here yes we
can Tim dude good to see you my friend
the 10 months Stargazer Tim has been a
member here get that overgrown death
noodle show who's boss yeah we got him
we took care of him
I guess that guy was just like I don't
know he transfigured a basilisk
look-alike in there
yeah I enjoy it too Timothy I do I like
the art style
very different for sure then and even
quite a bit different than what we've
seen out of a Hogwarts
Wizarding World game before too
you should return to your dormitories
young treasure Seeker this dude's up to
something
he's up to something
what matters do you think oh yeah
wait maybe he was the guy
maybe he was the guy
maybe he's mocking us he is a professor
after all
or maybe he's looking for the same thing
on the wall
man I'm disappointed I was hoping that'd
be the moment we got to relive thank you
and good luck with your secret okay I
know at some point you're gonna get to
relive other moments from the series so
far the only one that's been like a big
battle was the Dumbledore Voldemort
moment and that happened very early in
the game we had that little bit of a
moment with Hermione there earlier
but it was it was like Hermione and The
Time Turner
but since then
I don't think we've seen any other big
ones
exactly GG you understood that reference
yep
up to something
at the hogshead Inn
where we're sure to get to who knows
what no no trouble
what could possibly go wrong
all right chapter three find the
entrance to the chamber that one is
checked off
and we have a task from Ivy now let's
see where are we at find Ivy oh and we
just unlocked this one
got our gold right there
oh so we knocked all those out perfect
okay so we're done with page one
done with page two
almost I think
yeah I think we're ready for this one
here
yep that's the one that's up next
okay so this one's not actually a
I'm trying to figure out how this so all
of this
is 2-3 that was 2-2
2-4 is right there okay so one two
there's three sections
and then we're at the end all right
we're making it we're making it we're
making it so we got one full page two
full pages
so two and a half pages left
all right let's go find ivy
there she is
what's the Mata too many late yeah we
haven't really seen her much in this
year
oh no nothing like that I just can't
seem to get a good night's sleep
if you're having trouble falling asleep
Madame Pomfrey might have something that
could help a sleeping draft oh I fall
asleep
what
in my dorm in the corridor on the
grounds they're so real I know it's
silly but they're just nightmares but
every time I visit one of those places
now I expect the dreams to come true
you're probably just not used to the
castle yet I still don't feel like her
story was fully resolved I know
I mean we got it we gotta try to find
our sister right
spoilers if you haven't finished Year
One
is about spiders
enter Ivy's dream
what magic is this
triumph over Ivy's nightmare
we kind of had a little bit of that in
year one at the very end
of my bed and onto my face I tried to
scream but of course I couldn't jeez
rachnophobe if you have Arachnophobia
look away
Look Away might want to turn down the
sound too oh my gosh that sounds awful
all right
Cornish pickle
swelling
get the spiders
oh that was quick oh
oh we're doing the we're doing we're
just going through all the nightmares
right here back to back to back
defeat the Dementors
foreign
swelling charm
our swelling solution I think he says
nice there we go
wait I thought that was my dragon
maybe that was who we saw in the
Slytherin common room
and the scorching breath engulfed me oh
wouldn't that be crazy Ivy's sister
when Ivy is summoned she will use a
powerful Vanishing spell once and defeat
the first opponent it hits keep this in
mind and save her for the right moment
that is a pretty powerful
um companion that's for sure
house what is up welcome in
good to see you
how's it going
okay let's see
Timothy maybe a little bit but probably
not because I don't think I don't have
an Xbox and I don't even think my PC
I could probably run it and play it but
I don't think I could stream it very
well that's for sure they're just not
are you pretty excited for it though
Ivy's a super powerful card it doesn't
yeah if it's like it it has to be really
I've ran into that a little bit too it's
like really precise
right by your side
but then one time Jenny I think what you
might be talking about is uh
I like threw her out and I don't know if
something hit her immediately and it
didn't it didn't actually work yeah
I won't be so scared the next time
especially with you by my side
I got you although if I show up in your
dreams instead
sweet dreams at honeydukes get it get it
get it yes exactly
sweet dreams
yeah that's how I use it too
to counter the big the Ron yep
[Music]
all right check on Ivy that is complete
talk to Alma at madame malkins
yeah you get so many cards going through
the story I probably should have done
this first but but you also have to be
at a certain level you know to get
through
all right who is this
I don't know why I
bought a new outfit won't change a thing
hello I don't mean to intrude but you
seem a little frustrated are you all
right yeah she does have to be in a
certain range Gigi you'll see like a
little circle
little circle that appears and you have
to like aim it right at the Target you
want to zap
ing
your outfit is amazing
dang retro throwing out the compliments
Alma or Alma
Wild
Maybe
what
like what glitter
funny I like you the thing is
looking you want to be unique okay okay
what amount of ideas do you have any
do you have any look at this
who is this person should I know who
this person is
Elma fixed her hair in front of the
mirror
oh look at you
new style
oh no am I actually gonna have to I'm
actually gonna have to answer aren't I
oh that's not it how about changing the
color retro you can't just
yes be honest but he's like no that's
not it
that's not it I'm sorry
that's not it
you'll know her eventually okay gotcha
he was brutally honest
I don't know about a spell but
we've got the hair raising potion
all right so now we gotta go talk to
Daniel right
well dude
I haven't even been over to this side
yet
wait zero
oh because I can use this
a student coupon
the eyeball on the end of the Hat
oh wait we got another set oh this is
like quidditch gear
then we had scarves and then we had
other hairstyles
wait let me go back to
I want to take off the hat
there we go
so wait why are some of them
and they're all free why are they free
maybe you get one free or something
I didn't even know this was over here
though I've never
I've never went to that side
oh no I don't want this hair that's not
oh is it just using the coupons
growing up in the South my family always
said coupons
anyone else ever call them coupons out
there
coupons instead of coupons
student deals IRL right
I know I need I'm waiting for her to
have something better like I don't
really love any of those the one on the
far right if I had to pick that would be
the one but all right let's go to let's
go talk to Daniel
but I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait until
I see something Draco hey if you're here
Draco do you know how long the
when does malkin's shop change
I don't think I've seen it change yet
I thought that'd be something that would
change all the time you grew up in the
South neither of your parents are from
there oh I gotcha
Sharina welcome Shireen
how's it going The Unlucky wheel I know
right
hair dying potion okay Daniel
and jumping Toadstool Serene and jumping
Toadstool how's it going
the higher your collection is the higher
your exploration attributes are
ex unpack that one for me
hire my collection is
it changes every day
just checked yesterday and she had
Madame Malcolm had the exact same stuff
and do you mean card collection
because I have 70 out of 75 cards
I'm just babysitting this potion lots of
starting required
Alma okay Alma
oh the furniture and wardrobe stuff
gotcha okay
Trisha all you want is that tiny puff of
owl
I think there is Gigi I think there is
we were wondering if you know a potion
that can change hair color
interesting question my sister dyes her
hair with smelly muggle Solutions but
the color is never bright enough
it's over her last birthday I found a
person that made her hair color much
more Vivid
see it looks like she's still talking
oh I bet I bet she's gonna ask us
the color she's gonna ask us for color
recommendations I mean it looks like
she's a Hufflepuff here so
I would look good with that yes I
she's wearing a lot of yellow
okay let's make
start brewing
oh it doesn't look like Hedwig though
I have the badger head
the lion head
I don't think I do where do I get where
do I check to see if I have it
in my mirror I guess I don't think I've
seen a lion head in there though
prep the ingredients
gotta do your daily task oh yours just
reset
hey well I appreciate you stopping by
thanks for all the comments I'm not sure
how to pronounce your name yelin yelin
thank you for stopping by Good Luck Good
Luck doing your dailies
stir three times anti-clockwise
is that what they really say
anti-clockwise do you guys say that in
in the UK
we say counterclockwise
the private room that has gossamer
oh my goodness five times one two three
four five
score at least 90 points all right we
got that
I'll control the temperature this one's
my favorite
125 raise the temperature now
same one oh a little bit faster
and we have learned the recipe
Jesse it's free so yeah it's worth
getting
no in all seriousness though I mean it I
I'm loving it I definitely think it's
worth wait get one
you get 150. I didn't miss anything
maybe getting it lined up exactly in the
middle on that one
in the UK you do say anti-clockwise and
by the way there's Paula Paula did I
miss you or is that your first comment
welcome in Paula good to see you
you say both antsy and counter okay nice
I was like I don't think I've ever heard
that term
anti or anti-clockwise
talk to Daniel again okay
it hurts your brain cloud says
but yeah Jesse I'm having a blast with
it I mean because it's free to play it's
like
if you're at all interested you can
download it and try it and if it's not
for you then you didn't you didn't spend
any money
all right let's go
what color did you say you wanted oh
here we go is she gonna ask us what do
you think wait what color are our eyes
blue
I think they're blue
she wants blue
go I would have picked blue if she asked
us
it doesn't sound like a real word what
do you think should I drink it I mean if
you're the one who said you wanted to
change
please believe in Daniel
wait is she like afraid he
Daniel knows what he's doing
nice see it worked your hair looks
incredible
Paula how's it been going
hope you're having a good day Paula
it is shockingly blue that's what she
wanted Daniel come on dude honestly
oh wait where is she she might be a
Ravenclaw
the scarf looks Hufflepuff but that tie
that looks blue and
or maybe that's black
dang retro go to the dance with me
I was just wondering if maybe you want
to go to the ball with me
hair dying person
I like it thanks again
going okay
well good to hear from you Paula
hope everything that that didn't sound
like a very strong things are going well
so hope things aren't too crazy for you
always enjoy seeing Paula stop by and
say hello
in the streams jumping Toadstool I
wouldn't call that shockingly blue yeah
it's not like a super bright blue
talk to Professor Longbottom
hey it's time to go pay Neville a visit
at the herbology classroom first I'm
going to look around in this room I feel
like there are always some little uh
little things to explore in this room oh
look at that
anything else
all right let's go see what Neville's up
to
Neville never long bottom
you heading out Ryan Ryan have a good
one
always good to see you Ryan
hello I'll see you in in Hogwarts for
today
Ryan is in our uh Social Club in the
game
exciting lesson
oh wait Bobo tubers
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
no booba tubers here Bobo tubers it's
got to be a typo right
oh great
Cassandra you won't get into any trouble
while I'm away and remember to wear your
dragon hide gloves
yo Neville just just leaving us just
like you guys got this
come on Neville
I know Trisha right I think that was a
typo
this is what I get for trying to be
independent you know like Cassandra Paul
have you been playing too it's so fun
isn't it I'm having a lot of fun with
the game
yeah Cassandra is a bit
snooty
look even her she's she's even got that
look of like
beneath me all the time
the wrong on it can get you killed or
Worse expelled
know what could be worse than sorry I
see that that's the first thing it makes
me think of
the runes Professor is worse right
jumping Toadstool I'm right there with
you it's been a big surprise for me as
well
then I'm sure you wouldn't mind
answering oh okay all right all right we
can play that game okay
answer Cassandra's questions
chat
uncontrollable laughter
it's not wormwood
I don't know that I've ever seen this in
Harry Potter
oh no we got two answers
oh we got two answers
I think I would have picked dried nettle
but I'm gonna trust you guys
chat for the win on that one
let's see if that was just a lucky nah
Cassandra we got we've got help
all right proceed to question two
wait what why do I have to click back
into it okay I know this one
this one is not harder Cassandra this
one is easier
I've had that Professor Longbottom
helped Harry Potter win a tri-wizard
tournament competition with gillyweed
you've been reading magical water plants
up the Mediterranean in your spare time
hmm one more question just do one more
question
okay
I'm gonna try to answer this one on my
own see if we can get two on our own
question three which ingredients is
vital for Brewing Skelly grow
okay that's book
two
it's dittany
oh no
cabbage
Kelly grow simply would not work without
it does it tell you that in the books I
don't remember that
way I do not remember that in the book
are you not going to work with me now
three oh I have to I have to get it
right
she's like no I'm sorry you're not I'm
not working with you until you get it
correct
[Music]
so you have to get them right before
proceeding
was Illuminating
now that I have an idea of your skill
level she said get good right
fetching me some fresh soil from over
there
fetching you oh here we go dude
here we go we just have to be like
the assistant for her
dig for fresh dirt wait isn't that what
we
oh we have to
oh we have to battle the Gnomes
no way
repel the Gnomes
protect the plants and repel the Gnomes
all right we got this oh look and we can
even
call her as a companion
she's a really good companion too
especially like on the little small ads
that
look at this
what a revolting odor is that a blast in
its Groot Greenhouse is no place for it
get rid of it quickly
accio can be used yep we learned Akio
earlier
defeat the blast ended scrut
in swelling
well wait we could have two of them
oh my gosh look at this
this is
that's crazy
and to Podium local line
I don't have accio in this deck though
so I can't pull them in
it's fine
I think we got it I think we've got it
under control anyway
better than I expected despite the
gnome's attacks my venomous tentacula is
still the best
oh I didn't mean to skip that
we both agree I am far better at
herbology correct it's always
interesting how some of the dialogue
options uh responses are just a little
bit different myself included
see myself included
I'll be holding my breath until then
thanks for allowing me to be your
partner
retro like humbling himself there just
just like
he already knows you just gotta let her
let her do her thing
find the entrance to hogsmead
all right let's see where we're at now
oh almost almost about to get a key
dye your hair blue
yeah
it'd be funny if we had that option
Transfiguration classroom
not with our current faces
oh poly juice time
Cassandra's not the only one who can
cast Advanced spells
potion take a month to brew you're right
but we don't have anything else to do at
the moment do we and don't you need
blood sucking leeches and the skin of a
highly poisonous boom slaying snake
right ah I assumed one of you would have
a pet boom slime snake
I once had a leech as a pet until it
fell off
why don't we just sneak in
Robin's right oh no apologies
cult you could do that invisibility
again we haven't
gossamer
without a poly juice potion oh
permission which we definitely don't
have and yet we're still going oh it's
Lottie with the
that's like Dad joke territory there
many secret passages
all of which are either caved in or
carefully guarded by films oh like the
one-eyed witch
defy creates diversion at one of the
entrances and get Future's attention
gossamer can lead you to another passage
that's brilliant but are you sure you
want to face filter alone
Noble sacrifice
man we always going up against filch in
this game
every time we turn around
gotta deal with filch
so Noble
oh and this is it behind the statue I
knew it
leads to assuming gazama was right what
if future closed it up
then I'm going to be very sad
I love sweets no he didn't close it up
he's going to totally mess this up isn't
he
fine I'll help him
Phil Sheffield she's still around
Mrs Norris is too Timothy that shocked
me I came to help you did not expect
Mrs Norris to still be around
if I gave you a sip you'd be totally
convinced that I was your best friend
you'd follow me anywhere you
thick as Flubber mucus you know that
what I've never used it
I suppose they could argue with each
other until filch comes
I don't need a potion oh no
the relationship is starting to uh
oh no
writing you know
or maybe maybe this is on purpose
oh oh oh it is
really
there he is Timothy
over here
you are not hogging all the credit for
this
hey they convinced me I thought it was
legit looks like that like them real
Sparks between Robin and Kevin
now's our chance say the password
gothamma gave us
sherbet lemon
descendium
still the same password huh
all right let's go into
into hogsmead
are we sure this is going to honeydukes
I don't smell anything sweet just mud
I think we're lost doesn't it seem like
we've been walking forever
what's that
hello
probably nothing doesn't look like
anything oh man I need to
eat a stretch
we don't have the stretch command over
here like we do on Twitch or the little
reward stuff that you can redeem
don't even fall
and supposedly
swelling Solution on the opal eye let's
go
oh my gosh there are so many of these
sure
dude that dragon is doing work over
there
look at him man
oh we've got Ron ready too watch this
um
get him Ron
are we gonna have two dragons
yes let's go
fantastic bombs
Corners Pixies oh my gosh this is crazy
I don't think they can hit the dragons
can they
seems like they're not able to hit the
dragons at all
oh my gosh dude this is
so much damage
we might as well put these guys out
there too there we go we got it
we got it anyway
wait no English rod
you're all right those little creatures
were so mean I love how she's constantly
drawing
at least it looked like that's I mean
maybe she's taking notes but it looked
like she's just always
stopping taking a moment to draw
something
here we are at the hog's head
for the first time we're not supposed to
what do you want from honey dudes
demigod what level is my deck I think
I'm
32. I believe
foreign yes do you know him
who's asking you are from the ministry
are you
do we look like we're from the ministry
that's just with a person uh Chris
there's still space in the social club
just started playing no our our main
Social Club is full and I'm I've had a
lot of people ask about joining so we're
gonna make a second one but I just need
somebody who wants to be the captain for
it so I don't know if you are
if you're in our Discord Krista but
that's where we're kind of coordinating
everything we have a magic awakened
section there so I just need somebody
who's not in our main one
to step up and say sure I'll lead the
the second one so we'll just call it
like house wrecking to house wrecking
two house wrecking tour two or something
like that
house wrecking tour like II maybe like
the Roman numerals
so yeah we're we're going to make
another one I'm just waiting to get
somebody who who is uh willing to do it
to be the captain
oh no they're going to use forbidden
forbidden spells coming up
no way
in this mission
[Music]
they really miss him
Harold's old friends
power out only friends on Knights and
the Titans in this bar I was reckon too
that
I didn't even think about that it is a
good name
you got me stuck with the name like I'm
stuck on this wall taken by a wizard who
thought I Knew Too Much
the other painting said you know about a
mop that leads to a rare magical
artifact
that I do I'm a rare artifact
the maps the back of the castle in the
grounds
we've looked everywhere around those
portraits
well you obviously haven't been pointed
in the right direction
back to be with your friends oh oh I'd
love to see the old gang
arrival time you have a vat you didn't
just grab a painting off the walls here
and walk off with it oh come on
the real thing you can always make a
copy Gemini oh look at you Lottie
to remove this
extremely big heavy portrait from the
bar without anyone noticing
reducio
look at you ivy
Professor Gorski oh there he is again
dude
that's a gorsky definitely
explain me to do I'm gonna get to the
bottom of this wait Daniel
Simon has ominous voice actor wait
actually
that's just like the pouch that cloaked
wizard in the chamber used to store the
Basilisk fan
dude I said they were the same guy but
maybe they're working together but that
would mean what's it to you
what are you kids doing here and why are
you meddling in a private business
matters of our patrons
oh no we gotta fight this guy
oh that's what you were saying about
unforgivables
actually you know what no let's wait
and then we're gonna get this
oh I just missed the swelling Solution
on it
yeah this seems like a good one to kind
of set up a little
oh no
no they almost got Cassandra right there
send the monster book through it as well
I love that the bomb goes to the dragon
too that's crazy
all right watch this
go get him Ron
oh
get him Ron
oh man I need the swelling Solution on
Ron
what just happened Ivy here we come
let's go Ivy nice
good timing good timing
yeah this definitely got a lot harder
they took out Ron quickly
oh no no no no
we gotta get over here
Daniel heal me please
can't get that close
if we have to though I think we have to
try
oh my gosh that spell is crazy man
all right let's get the twins out
try to get rid of the troll at least
okay troll is gone
I can't move
oh my gosh this Ventus
no we're gonna die right here we're
gonna die we're gonna die we're gonna
die we're dead
I can't even see we're dead
all right yeah
whoever gave us the warning you were not
kidding this is tough
all right let's try again entering
battle please wait for a moment
I'm not gonna waste Ron at the beginning
I'll tell you that we used Ron way too
early
I think is this guy stuck
yeah I don't know what was happening
there he just
he just stayed there for a second
yeah I'm not gonna use Ron this time so
early
I'm gonna hang back
Cornish Pixies
all right let's save up for
dragon and swelling
so we need eight for that oh no
all right actually let's go ahead and
put dragon out
and then get swelling on both of them
gotta get out of the way of that
oh it took out our niffler man
okay oh yeah we're already doing much
better
monster book
let's go over here
nice
although we just had to
fix that now
I was thinking about calling out Ron too
but I'm gonna might try to wait on Ron
oh great not that thing again
it's India
oh that was a good incendio right there
oh I think we almost got him
is that it
there we go call out wrong I know I I
could have used Ron but I
I was waiting to see if there was
another moment where even more came out
but
never even had to use him
oh McGonagall this time oh
she's right there
[Music]
find the entrance to hogsmead
all right let's see
yes we just got a key
all right so we have two more on this
page
then another full page and then three
more on the last page all right let's go
ahead and let's knock these two out for
sure talk to Kevin at the library
all right there he is
or more likes to hit 50. hey thank you
guys so much for all the likes today
appreciate the support
if you're watching this later in the
replay Squad leave a comment below let
us know you were here
Sacramento
what could you possibly have to do with
the giant spider
oh we gotta go into the forest
okay I lost a favorite coffee you he
lost it
and now you want me to help find it
would you I know exactly where it is but
according to my research that puts it
right in the middle of acrimental
territory
of course of course don't suppose we
could just buy Robin a new waffle
no she loves
that Photograph by every member of the
Holy head harpies
oh my goodness Kevin
and not get caught or eaten
all right into the Forbidden Forest I'm
guessing yep head to the Forbidden
Forest with Kevin
oh yeah I haven't checked this in a bit
couple echoes
go talk to Kevin oh he's over here
wow
look at all the spider webs
at least we know we're going in the
right direction are we huh lovely
I can't believe we're doing this and it
was my idea it was indeed
it's Robin squawful oh let's go let's
just let's grab it and get out of here
won't have to fight anything will we
right not gonna have to fight anything
you guys
oh no another one
what is he doing here
oh wait did did we not see
oh there's two there's two
It's Kind this way
Dog Wizard
can catch it before it Finds Its mates
we can still get the Venom
I'm telling you a hundred galleons a
point sounded a lot better back at the
hog's head if I'd known with the elbow
deep okay so the professor is paying
these guys
save your whining for when we finish the
job come on to get acrimential of venom
OTS no they ain't at Cincinnati are we
gonna have to obliviate him
don't worry yeah
won't feel nothing but a tickle
face the dark Wizards
confront
come on confront them
man back to back dark wizard battles huh
oh and spiders no way
it's literally what it says spiders and
dark Wizards
okay fulfill the fantasy of setting
spiders on your foes from your very own
acromantula nest
okay let's put it like back here
oh my goodness I have never used this
spell
we'll periodically spawn spiderlings
oh look there he goes
I can't move it's not letting me do
anything else
spiders are attacking the dark Wizards
beat the dark Wizards
what if I do this
and then I do swelling solution
wait where'd it go oh there it is
oh yes
fantastic
oh my gosh
these spiders are going crazy
Lucia hello there welcome
how's it going
oh Max of three
that's it we got him
we got him
okay I don't need to check in with that
again
head to haggarid's Hut
Lucia how's your day going
have you played any magic awakened yet
because that's
what I've been doing a lot lately
a lot of magic awakened
all right talk to Kevin
no we're good Kevin we made it we made
it Kevin safe and sound in Hagrid's
pumpkin patch those wizard
whoops didn't mean to skip that
wait is he mad
is he mad
he's not happy
you're playing right now nice let's go
it's a really fun game
to help me find it we never would have
run into those spider poachers if it
wasn't for me spider poachers
I think they were after Aquaman oh yep
definitely yes I solemnly swear never to
sneak into the Forbidden Forest again no
matter who asks
it was your idea
all right
let's see where that puts us now
oh my goodness that was just the one
section I thought that was at least two
sections right there
no
all right let's go ahead we gotta go
ahead and at least do this one
gotta at least finish this one out Robin
doesn't look happy I wonder what's
happened
oh boy
good yeah you must have seen it tell me
you saw it
um so what exactly
storm over the Quidditch it's
been how am I supposed to practice with
all that lightning
Robin thinks a Thunderbird is causing it
a Thunderbird I mean it's a big storm
with thunder and lightning and it came
out of where
oh they misspelled lightning says
lighting
fear come on I'll show you oh let's go
investigate
you say that and then what's the first
thing we always do something crazy hey
hey wait for me
wait for me
are we actually gonna get to fly I think
we might
I think we might be flying at the
Quidditch pitch for this one
yes
lying is pretty hard with the controls
like on PC
all right
I don't know Robin the weather looks
fine to me
I don't understand what
a few okay that's weird
stands outside with a lightning rod
right
whoa
okay wait how did we miss that
from above
yeah let's just fly right in the middle
of it
okay explore the skies
explore now yes
yes
I don't know why it does that sometimes
it's like it
just doesn't start instantly there it
goes takes a little extra second
oh my goodness we're in quidditch
uniforms
wait what is this
looks like the weather is going from bad
to worse and we're just flying right in
the middle of it you see Robin I told
you can we land now please
let's just fly right oh she actually got
struck no way hurry use the invigoration
draft
there we go
I'm not in control of the flight at all
right now just kind of doing it on its
own
wait what was that we did we didn't find
out anything
or did we
now it's sunny again are you okay what
is happening
painful
just a little dizzy and a little
numbness in the head that's all
[Music]
I'm fine really
you just need to lie down for a week
wait was she right is it actually a
Thunderbird
no way
yeah Hagrid
get this thing under control why is it
over here
she was right
yep she did
she did get struck
wait so we're just gonna leave the the
Thunderbird We're not gonna talk about
that
wait now we're doing quidditch practice
how are you feeling Robin any better
did I miss something here
did anyone see the Thunderbird yeah
we did actually
all right Hagrid
what no storm at all
wait wait
um
[Music]
we definitely saw a Thunderbird we
definitely saw one
I don't know what that was about
let's get your rest before heading back
to the skies quidditch can wait
oh wait
for which sticks
like waiting
[Music]
all right I think that should have
marked off
yes it did all right
nice and we're ready to go to
Transfiguration
I think that's a great place to stop
I actually thought we'd be able to to go
all the way through today but
it's gonna be dinner time here pretty
soon so I think I'm gonna call it there
but man a lot of uh super chats today
especially from radical radical
appreciate that had expect to go in
there with a super chat as well
and lots of new subs today thank you
guys all for the new Subs appreciate it
Anna oh my goodness Anna we were just
wrapping up yes indeed
but I'm glad you stopped by for a bit
hey that's the cool thing about YouTube
you can just you can rewind it right
from the start
[Music]
no problem Jenny thank you for being
here I'm probably gonna need I don't
know if you're gonna be on later I need
to get a dance in with somebody in our
club actually any of the three of you
Anna Jenny or Gigi all in our social
club I think that's all that I need for
my for my daily tasks it's just too hard
to do on PC so I'm gonna wait so I can
hop on my phone for a bit later
but yeah thank you guys for being here
we'll have to do this again
but uh stay tuned if you're not
following us over on Twitter that's
where we post usually when we go live
somewhere I also try to make sure I post
it here on the Community page as well
but we've just been kind of splitting
our time between YouTube and twitch
right now when it comes to the live
stream so
if any of you who watch this later in
the VOD have any any preference or
anything if you guys prefer one to
another I feel like we have a lot of the
same people who watch on either one so
just kind of splitting our time between
both until until I see a reason to to
stick with one
Shireen thank you for being here as well
Gigi you need a dance too actually you
know what let's if you want let's do it
right now and I'll show everybody What
It's Like on PC I'm just gonna pick a
very
I'm gonna pick the very easy one
I'm gonna pick the level one
if that's okay with you
I don't know if you're online yet or not
you're gonna hop on oh yeah Gigi has to
like she watches on the phone
I don't even think I could would
complete it if I did hard Alicia
actually I don't know can you fail can
you outright fail because we definitely
we wouldn't complete it
I'll do level two I'll do level two to
give it at least a little bit of a of a
challenge
but level five is actually Impossible on
PC as far as I know
too hard I'm not I'm you can't you like
you actually can't do it
if it was something that was just
difficult I would do it
but you like you'll have circles on the
opposite sides of the screen
even some of four needs the two fingers
I've almost gotten S rank in all the
fours but I don't I don't even know why
I'm bothering Jenny I don't think I'm
ever gonna be able to get it
and uh
in the five star I don't think I'm ever
gonna be able to
[Music]
oh that's too funny trust me you'll see
Alicia two even like two is hard on on
PC
level five is just like
I I don't know how you get an S rake on
that it's just they they introduce
totally new mechanics
that haven't been in any of the level
fours
very very strange
all right let's see here
let's do
putty foot's gaze I'm gonna put it on
level two
yeah I mean I guess that's the only way
like you have to like straight up
memorize it
all right it's still pretty tough even
on on level two here we go
right
like see that was pretty far away
who almost missed that one
it's when you get those quick ones that
are like somewhat far apart
okay not too bad right now
and then sometimes because the mouse is
like this orange color
I lose it in the gold of the
I bet you can change the color of the
mouse though that's probably a blue
Stacks thing I can change
[Music]
oh
by the way if anybody watching is
wondering how I'm playing this on PC uh
like right there I couldn't see I
couldn't see where my
couldn't see the cursor
[Music]
and we still got
Triple S rank hey let's go
I know Jenny that's so true you can't
it's hard to watch them while you're
actually
playing when you're doing it
okay so we only had I didn't even
realize you could get a triple S rank
getting some that are only good
well that's that's nice to know Gigi
thank you for this dance
now we can mark that off I can check
that off I've got all my Social Clubs
done for the day
how I do that on PC you're struggling on
mobile that was just level two
but yeah I've almost gotten all of the
level fours done in an S ranker above
but I don't think I'm ever gonna be able
to get level 5's S rank that's just too
difficult
mutant Pogo by the way thank you for
being here
all right guys hope everybody has a
wonderful wonderful weekend you guys
already know I'll see you on Magic awake
and we gotta be knocking out our dailies
we gotta keep our top 100 rank house
rack and tour we're there right now
we gotta keep it up Luna wants out yeah
I'm talking about you talking to you
you always went out and then you went in
and then you went out and then you went
in
she's like yeah like now please
all right guys have a good one thank you
all for being here I will see you again
very soon
foreign